[Musique]
mais où sont passés les extraterrestres
salut vous l'avez compris on va
s'intéresser à la question suivante
pourquoi nous ne sommes pas encore en
contact avec les extraterrestres les
reptiles bien sont ils déjà parmi nous
déguiser en mentalist bon ça déjà la
réponse c'est non
c'est exactement ce que dirait un
reptilien ça c'est pas faux je vais vous
parler du paradoxe de fermi enrico était
un physicien italien c'est faux c'était
un musicien qui chantait données données
de enrico fermi était un physicien
italien qui en 1950 a posé la question
suivante s'il existe des civilisations
extraterrestres leurs représentants
devraient déjà être parmi nous alors
vraiment où sont ils on les cherche à 8
ans à vie la phrase exacte qui devrait
prononcer lors d'un dîner et where is
everybody
du coup tout à fait spontané qui me
vient je voulais dire non parce que je
la connais déjà en fait ta réponse ils
sont dans mon nom d'ante et dans ses
hypothèses que nous allons voir à partir
de maintenant si les extraterrestres
existent ils ont peut-être trouvé la
solution à l'un de mes fantasmes le
téléchargement de savoir directement
dans le cerveau à la matrix ou la total
recall on en n'est d'ailleurs pas très
dense jusqu'en 2016
une étude qui a été reconfirmé en 2017 a
démontré qu'une stimulation électrique
améliorer l'apprentissage de la
connaissance de l'aviation par des
novices et jeudi améliorer j'aurais même
dû dire accélérons n'est pas près de
devenir les eaux mais en attendant on a
à ce moment une solution très efficace
pour apprendre du savoir concret c'est
open classroom dont je vous parlerai en
fin de la vidéo qui sponsorise cette
vidéo et qui permet entre autres de
faire une formation diplômante en ligne
rémunéré par une entreprise et en
commençant n'importe quand dans l'année
je vous en reparle dans la fin de la
vidéo vous avez un lien dans la
description
[Musique]
pour le moment pour répondre aux
paradoxes de ce lauréat du prix nobel
comme m
il faut comprendre deux choses notre
système solaire est un jeune enfant
comparé à l'âge des étoiles de notre
galaxie ou de galaxies plus monteyne
d'ailleurs donc on aurait dû trouver
même par hasard des traces des habitants
des systèmes bien plus vieux que le
nôtre même des civilisations disparues
on aurait fait des petites recherches
comme sartre et aux logiques inter
solaire un terreau système planétaire
je vais éviter d'utiliser des mots que
je comprends pas dans cette vidéo il
existe beaucoup de réponses viables
paradoxe de fermi mais elles ont presque
tout le même défaut c'est celui de
considérer l'histoire des
extraterrestres comme étant un peu la
même chose que celle des humains comme
sylvie extraterrestes devait passer ou
aller passer un moment donné par la
forme de notre civilisation actuelle
d'ailleurs on représente les
extraterrestres par des formes
humanoïdes dire avec des bras des yeux
une bouche on imagine qu'ils auraient
forcément des intentions envers nous ses
intentions sont catégorisées entre
bonnes ou mauvaises
on cause dire qu'ils voyageraient par
des moyens de transport qui ressemble un
petit peu notre alors non on n'a pas des
vaisseaux spatiaux mais dans l'idée ça
ressemble quand même au genre de
transport qu'on peut inventer nous bref
on les imagine un peu trop humain et on
appelle ça l'anthropomorphisme en 1961
de l'astronome france grec a écrit
l'équation de drake
c'est assez logique une équation qui
vise à déterminer combien il y aurait
deux civilisations extraterrestres juste
dans notre galaxie qui est pour info
composée de centaines de planètes pas je
veux dire de sorte n 2 milliards de
planètes
sachant que la voie lactée est vieille
de 13 milliards d'années c'est vrai
qu'ils auraient eu le temps quand même
de grandir un petit peu n'importe où en
parallèle de nous
[Musique]
et que ça quand on y pense c'est pas une
hypothèse si bête déjà est-ce qu'ils
utilisent les même nombre que nous pour
communiquer est ce qu'il cherche dans la
bonne direction la voie lactée m mesure
100 mille années lumière de diamètre et
je l' ai déjà dit à possède des
centaines de milliards des toiles faut
se mettre à leur place aussi comment ils
vont nous trouver alors qu'on n'a même
pas vraiment colonisé une autre planète
de notre propre système solaire gedar on
est allé sur la lune on a mis un drapeau
n'est reparti quoi pourquoi il serait
déjà tombé sur nous plutôt que sur
d'autres formes de vie qui sont elles
mêmes d'ailleurs peut-être plus proche
de chez eux que nous on est par rapport
à eux de chez eux
on peut même émettre l'hypothèse en se
disant qu'il ya des endroits de la
galaxie où il ya plein plein plein plein
de monde que c'est hyper dense et que
nous par un mauvais hasard en tout comme
ça on est né tout seul dans un coin
paumé de l'univers un endroit où
personne ne vient jamais nous voir parce
qu'ils sont tous ceux réunis sur le même
secteur
[Musique]
nous écoutons l'espace en permanence
mais à l'échelle de l'humanité on vient
juste de commencer à faire ça notre
recherche d'autres formes de vie à moins
d'un siècle et ça fait à peine 60 ans
contre décrypte les ondes présentes dans
la voie lactée
et tout ça en admettant que les
satellites soit pointé au bon endroit
à ce jour on est capable d'analyser plus
de 800 millions de fréquences
différentes mais qu'est-ce qui se
passerait si les messages avaient été
envoyées avant sur les ondes là qu'on
savait pas encore détecté ou s'ils
utilisaient simplement pas du tout ce
procédé
mais un autre qui est complètement
inconnu pour nous aujourd'hui c'est
comme si en 1789 on avait voulu passer
un coup de téléphone à louis saez halo
louis saez supporte dire de faire
attention aux attention j'aime bien ça
va couper
voilà bah il y aura une personne pour
décrocher le téléphone le seul truc qui
se seraient décrochés d'ailleurs c'est
sa tête en 1793 dans l'analyse de ce que
nous captons nous cherchons surtout la
répétition d'un signal en fait ça
signifierait qu'un signal est envoyé
s'il y avait une onde ou un truc comme
ça qui se répétaient de manière cyclique
mais ça ça aussi ça c'est peut-être un
réflexe de notre pensée humaine le fait
de chercher une répétition ce qui nous
paraît logique pour nous de notre point
de vue ça ne l'est peut-être pas du
point de vue d'un extraterrestre alors
s'il ya bien du coup des signaux un peu
chelou qu'on a capté qui se sont pas
répétés à chaque fois on a trouvé des
hypothèses plus crédible qu'un signal
qui viendrait des extraterrestes pour
les expliquer c'est le principe du
rasoir d'occam que je me ferais un
plaisir d'ailleurs de vous expliquer sur
instagram aujourd'hui dans une vidéo
très courte
oui instagram oui messieurs puisque la
majorité d'entre vous connaissent déjà
le réservoir d'eau calme donc je vais
pas le faire ici
quoi qu'il en soit la recherche des
signaux et très délicate voici un
extrait d'une déclaration de michael
gillon je pense que cette division qui
est spécialisée dans la recherche
d'exoplanètes des travaux ont montré que
la façon la plus économique serait de
communiquer de proche en proche en
utilisant les étoiles comme des radio
téléscopes géants la puissance
nécessaire est alors dérisoires de
quelques watts seulement tuer des
extraterrestres utiliser cette méthode
il viserait les bords des soleils un
endroit où nous n'écoutons pas ce serait
tout à fait normal alors quand est rien
vu d'ailleurs il aurait dû dire rien
entendu du coup parce que si on écoute
pas bah regardez moi bien avec les
oreilles
[Musique]
quand on y réfléchit ça c'est pas idiot
non plus est ce qu'il existe seulement
d'autres formes de vie intelligente mais
intelligente au sens où nous on l'entend
également à l'échelle de notre planète
est encore plus de notre galaxie ou de
l'univers nous sommes apparus il ya une
seconde à peine et à l'échelle de
l'évolution de la vie sur terre
les premiers organismes et les tout
petits les unicellulaires ils sont
apparus il ya 3,8 milliards d'années
alors que les premiers homo
l'australopithèque l'homo habilis etc
ils sont apparus il ya seulement 4
millions d'années environ
du coup la question se pose et c'est ce
que nous appelons extra terrestres
étaient seulement que des bactéries ou
des organismes unicellulaires peut-être
aussi il utilise simplement pas de
technologies avancées dont peut-être pas
de technologie tout court en fait on
imagine systématiquement linverse c'est
une habitude de pensées très humaine
on se dit toujours il utilise du high
tech qui utilisent plein de trucs comme
nous mais en fait on n'en sait rien
[Musique]
si l'histoire notre planète a nous a
appris quelque chose c'est que rien est
acquis il ya déjà eu plein d'extinction
de masse dans notre lointain passé et
d'autres qui ont lieu là actuellement
est le plus souvent qui sont dues à
l'activité humaine
et encore je ne parle pas des guerres de
l'armement nucléaire des apparitions des
nouvelles formes de virus à cause de
l'activité humaine de l'épuisement des
ressources du dérèglement climatique à
cause de l'activité humaine bref on est
la preuve qu'en peu de temps on s'est
tiré pas mal de buts décisifs contre
notre propre équipe donc il est
envisageable de dire que les
extraterrestres se sont eux aussi
autodétruit à un moment donné
donc il serait apparu bien avant nous il
se serait on va dire la civilisation
aurait augmenté et amélioré bien avant
nous il se serait auto détruit bien
avant en 1930 ce cher constantin si le
caustique et que comme vous le voyez
écrit ici tu l'a écrit là loïc à
d'accord tu peux me le dire ce que tu as
écrit bien sûr konstantinov c'est ouf
comment ta voix elle change quand tu
prends un accent comme ça c'est
incroyable
constanta a posé les bases de
l'hypothèse du zoo alors cette théorie
admet que la terre a déjà été référencés
par d'autres formes de vie qui ne
veulent pas parasiter notre évolution ou
alors qu'ils nous trouvent complètement
inintéressant ou trop hostile pour
entrer en contact avec nous dans les
deux cas on serait trop primitif pour
eux ou alors on peut se référer à
l'hypothèse du planétarium formulée par
stephen baxter qui imagine un truc à la
stargate
en gros notre monde aura été créé par
une autre forme de vie qui nous aurait
posé là pour nous faire croire que tout
est normal alors après peut-être ils
nous observent peut-être ils font
d'exécution rien sur nous peut-être
qu'ils vont après nous prendre comme
exploits sexuels sur une autre planète
je sais pas on sait pas pour faire quoi
[ __ ] j'ai eu peur quand ali je te
prendrai
[Musique]
oui si on aimait toutes les hypothèses
on est obligé d'émettre si celle ci
n'est pas impossible à 100% non plus en
tout cas c'est pas assez impossible pour
ne pas être dans ses hypothèses même si
c'est très peu crédible il est possible
que les contacts les déjà eu lieu et des
deals aurait été passé avec des
personnes ou des gouvernements des trucs
comme ça alors pourquoi il serait là
parmi nous bon je laisse les
complotistes du net vous donner les
raisons mais dans ce cas ça voudrait
dire qu'ils ont réussi à tenir
physiquement jusqu'à la terre et donc à
maîtriser toutes les problématiques
liées à la vitesse qu'il faut pour
voyager dans l'univers et c'est à cause
de ça que franck selsis a dit
civilisation existe ailleurs et doit y
avoir une taille critique à partir de
laquelle elle se développera ailleurs
dans l'univers
sinon elle reste confinée sur sa planète
ou à ses abords
quoi qu'il en soit pour le moment il ya
surtout deux camps il ya ceux qui
souhaitent activant rentrer en
communication avec notre forme de
civilisation et d'autres comme l'était
d'ailleurs stephen hawking qui au
contraire veulent absolument éviter ça
ils craignent que l'arrivée sur terre
d'une autre civilisation ressemble un
peu à l'arrivée des européens en
amérique avec tout ce qu'on a fait subir
de terribles aux indiens d'amérique donc
ils se disent ils sont plus évolués
qu'ils arrivent ils vont ils vont nous
imposer un dieu où ils vont tuer à huile
il a dit pas cool revenons à cette
centrale de savoir bien terrienne dont
je vous parlais en début de vidéo qui
s'appelle open classeront c'est
potentiellement à des futur de
l'humanité puisque cette un centre de
formation en ligne que vous connaissez
déjà bien si comme moi vous êtes
autodidacte et que vous êtes formé à la
tech par ce site opel cas seront
maintenant c'est aussi une manière
d'avoir un diplôme accrédité par l'état
de bac +2 à bac +5 dans les métiers du
numérique c'est 100% en ligne pour les
courts plutôt pratique à cette période
vous pouvez commencer à n'importe quel
moment de l'année avec des horaires
flexibles ce qui vous permet aussi de
commencer à travailler en entreprise dès
le début de la formation vous serez donc
sur des projets professionnalisant tout
en étant suivi par un mentor que vous
avez en vision une fois par semaine je
trouve le concept vraiment bien ficelé
votre formation elle peut être
directement financé par l'entreprise ou
par pôle emploi et les formations durent
entre six mois et 24 mois ça ça dépend
du parcours que vous choisissez au delà
du savoir et du partenariat puisque je
suis clairement là en train de faire un
partenariat pour open classroom ben je
trouve ça très cool parce que ça permet
d'avoir une vraie expérience
professionnelle dans un secteur qui
recrute actuellement
alors comment ça se passait bien il faut
postuler à une formation pour ça je vous
mets
la description et vous allez pouvoir
commencer votre candidature et pendant
le processus d'admission vous devrez
fournir une lettre de motivation vous
aurez un appel téléphonique etc voilà si
vous cherchez à faire une formation
diplômante dans les métiers du numérique
je trouve que c'est une bonne
opportunité
foncez sur le lit merci open classeront
si vous ne connaissez pas je m'appelle
fabien olicard vous pouvez vous abonner
à cette chaîne c'est gratuit et activer
la cloche pour être sûr de voir la
prochaine vidéo leakée cette vidéo si
elle vous a plu et à côté de moi je vous
mets deux autres vidéo qui devrait vous
intéresser une vidéo sur les films
mandela qui expliquerait que quelqu'un
modifie notre passé et là une vidéo sur
la terre qui serait plate ou pas à très
bientôt
ciao